can you share your reasoning for moving
to los angeles to become a filmmaker
i was in college in chicago and at the
time i thought i was going to be
like either an english professor or a
film studies professor that's what i was
studying and then the film club at
university of chicago
they acquired like a clunky old video
camera
and i picked up that video camera and i
checked it out and i
went and shot my first film and
simultaneously i knew
it was both terrible and that i didn't
want to do anything else but make films
and so at the time honestly like i
didn't know how to
do anything separate from going to
school and i was like if i want to be a
filmmaker i guess i'll
go to school to be a filmmaker and i
applied to the ucla film program
and got in and that's what brought me
out here and i'm not really thankful
about that
i don't know that my sort of 22 year old
self
would have just made the classic just
leap and move to la and so
going to film school was really my like
pull to los
angeles to show up here and start this
journey how was that for
you when you showed up because if you
were used to chicago winters and
i know there's a difference east coast
mindset versus west coast how did you
feel when you showed up here
i would say it took me a while to adjust
to los angeles for many reasons it's
just
very different place but really at the
time i think the city was much less on
my mind it was more i was you know i
showed up at grad school and it was 24 7
thinking about movies
and that was just wonderful like that
was really it's one of the most
memorable times my entire life
and so when i think about my arrival to
la i can't separate it from
it was the time when i fully set out
loud this crazy idea
i'm going to be a filmmaker uh and i
dropped an ucla and i met
uh you know i met lifelong friends i met
my wife
uh and really uh yeah just sort of
confirmed my like hope that this is
something i wanted to do
do you remember what movie was popular
at the time oh boy
um let's see what were the big ones you
know i don't know it was popular but i
know that uh i had seen a series of
movies in the in the few years leading
up to that time that had pushed me
towards
uh making films and they're very
different one of them was uh terence
malk's the thin red line uh i love
terence malek especially early malloc
um and then uh the matrix had come up
relatively uh close to that time
and as far apart as those two movies are
they were both movies that when i sat in
the theater and saw them
i just blown away and just moved on a
like emotional level a visual level
and i knew like yeah i want to do that
from listening to other interviews with
you you said you grew up
exposed to two very different cultures
and i was wondering how does that
shape your problem solving whether it's
on set
or even in life i'm a mixed-race
american so my dad is this muslim
immigrant from bangladesh and my mom
is she grew up in new england she's a
you know spanish italian white girl
and that really meant that in my
household like one of our guiding
principles was
there's always more than one way to do
things you know we celebrated christmas
and eat at thanksgiving we had turkey
and turkey biryani
but for sure yeah it has meant that in
almost every situation when i make an
artistic choice or a logistical choice
i think just very naturally i think
there are different perspectives i need
to think about all the different ways to
even ask the question in front of us let
alone find a solution
did you feel a pressure to abandon your
art or creativity i mean was
going to la to become a filmmaker or
something that was embraced i grew up in
a house
that loved movies my parents took me to
see art house films blockbuster films we
rented
you know everything we can get out of
blockbuster my
my bangladeshi relatives had vhs tapes
were being sent from india bollywood
films
uh so no uh if anything i think my
parents were maybe more excited about me
being a filmmaker than i was at times
like i think everyone
kept saying to me like i think you
should do this like you're the one
whenever we go see a movie
we spend an hour talking about you know
camera choices and what the actors did
so i often joke that i think my friends
and family realized i was going to be a
filmmaker before i did
what makes a great story i think there
are a lot of
different kinds of great stories
for me a great story
uh evokes emotion and it doesn't have to
be positive emotion just
i think to viscerally evoke emotion uh
is the first part of it i think i also
want a story
to feel like it has purpose and i don't
think that means it has to have a moral
or that it has to have a particular
structure
but i want to feel like i'm in the hands
of a storyteller
who has a plan and i'm excited to see
what their plan is
one of the things i love about stories
is that i think that they're a way of
seeing
how other people think and feel and if i
can sit down and read something or watch
something
and go on a journey through someone
else's mind and their point of view
and they're just feelings about life or
the world or whatever it is
i'm satisfied do you remember the first
film you saw as a child in the cinema
like a blockbuster film and then at some
point in art house cinema film
and how did each one leave you afterward
the very first movie i saw in the
theater was e.t
and you know that was at a time i wasn't
consciously thinking about the
filmmaking process but
the movie just made such an impression
on me and for reasons that i can't
explain
but my parents report when we walked out
of the theater
i said i want to be a filmmaker i want
to be a director
and at the time they said that's not
someone who watches movies that's
someone who makes movies do you know
that
and apparently i said no i know i then
promptly forgot about that for years and
i didn't actually aspire to be filmmaker
too much later but e.t
like just the magic of that movie really
struck me
and then when i was in high school uh i
saw paris texas
and just seeing an indie film that was
both gritty and lyrical and had sort of
elliptical storytelling
and was ambiguous at times that
really sort of hit me hard realizing wow
like film can be this like purely
emotional
art form that is not just about plot or
about
cool moments of action or this and that
that it can be an exploration of like
profound questions about life and it can
just be a visceral
experience and and that's really i think
that's really those two things like the
love of the power of the blockbuster but
also
the interestingness of like arthouse
cinema both of those remain very
important to me today
and maybe to some of the unanswered
questions because i feel like with a lot
of hollywood films they kind of want to
tie up the ending for you
so everything's safe and neat and clean
i
love films that ask prompt more
questions than answers i think you can
obviously go overboard you can make a
film that is just so incomprehensible
that i think you lose your audience but
for me the films that i love the most
that stay with me the most
are the ones that make me ask big
questions about
what happened what the meaning of things
is but hopefully those questions are
like
actually expanding out into my life and
making me ask questions about life
itself
when you say so ambiguous that you lose
your audience i mean is it is it
something that's just like this
experimental like swedish film that like
we don't totally but it's it's very
beautifully done or something i mean
like what
i think that as long as as a filmmaker
as long as
you are consciously being ambiguous
you're probably in good shape
i think that sometimes the only mistake
can be uh when i'm watching a film and i
feel like is this unclear
on purpose or is this a feeling of the
film
and to me it's like once you verge over
to i'm not sure if i'm supposed to
be in a gray area or not that's when i
get lost
i'm not sure exactly what you do with
your students in terms of the curriculum
and what they're turning into
but do you see that from from not just
your students but other filmmakers
online where you feel like they were
trying to be unclear and whether it
works or not
ah you know i think that actually like
most like the vast majority of
filmmaking these days because it's so
heavily influenced by
blockbuster culture actually just leans
towards clarity
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with clarity i think in some ways like
the beauty of clarity is that it creates
a result
in the way you wanted it to so more
often than not i'm actually pushing my
students though in an attempt to sort of
diversify
cinema to contemplate but maybe there is
a value to an open-ended question
maybe there is a value to it at some
points the audience not quite
understanding what's happening
even if it's just to have the reward of
them figuring it out so i feel like i
more push them that way than have to
sort of rein them back from ambiguity
do you see them trying to emulate
certain directors i know
you know generation x they wanted to be
robert rodriguez or
whatever and i still see people that are
you know gen z saying the same thing but
do you see
do you see certain people they're trying
to emulate all the time i think so many
of us
come to movies to become film we come to
becoming filmmakers
because we loved certain filmmakers and
i do think just a natural part of the
artistic process
to whether you're doing it consciously
or not evoke some of the vernacular some
of the tropes of the filmmakers you love
i don't think it's necessarily a bad
thing uh because i think that's actually
usually a route towards eventually
finding your own voice
you know if you look at someone like
tarantino probably one of the most
emulated filmmakers
he himself is so in love with certain
kinds of movies
but his entire voice is based on taking
those films and adding his twists
so i actually yeah i think that i
encourage my students if they like
something
to play in that and to figure out how to
make it their own i think that's really
what leads to finding your own voice
how did you learn to be a film director
i started
my like film making sort of adventure
entirely self-taught in the sense that i
just got my hands on a video camera that
my college film club happened to have
and i reverse engineered how to make a
movie i knew i had seen movies
and i just took a guess at how they must
produce the footage that led to that
and so for my first year of making
movies i didn't have any formal
education i didn't even have books on
filmmaking it was sort of prior to the
real explosion
in blogs and and youtube channels and
books about all that sort of stuff
after that year uh then i went to film
school
and for me film school was a great
experience i went to grad film school
and so it was this like
amazing three four year period of my
life where i just
had the privilege of thinking almost
exclusively about
the process of making movies and that
meant
learning production logistical things
how to schedule a movie and how to
budget it
but it also meant learning an artistic
process and hearing from different
artists about that
and so i think i'm glad that i started
my exploration without any formal
structure
because it let me just learn some things
without some previous assumptions that
other teachers or guides might have
but then i was also glad to have a
series of people who were pretty
experienced
give me their point of view on
filmmaking as well you said your father
was an architect
yeah so did you sort of instinctually
look at things in in almost a similar
way the way he approached
problem solving looking back my father
and i actually had this conversation now
where we realized i think there is
actually a lot of similarity between
architecture and film
i think they are both concerned with
time and space in a certain way
uh and they are both art forms where the
idea is not the completion of the art
form
you can imagine a building and you can
imagine a film but
the art form is not complete unless it
can actually be realized
and so i think that sort of a
combination of
the logistics necessary to make a thing
and your artistic desire for what you
want it to be the way they intersect and
can
conflict or sometimes be complementary
there's a lot of similarities i think
between those two so
i don't know if that's why i became a
filmmaker but i think certainly i'm
interested in the fact that he's an
architect and i'm a filmmaker
do you see that with your students at
all in terms of they approach it from
just one side when you try to show them
sort of both sides
of not just you know maybe they get so
focused in one area oh they just had
want to have you know this line of
dialogue and it's going to be really
funny and
bam bam bam all these great funny lines
but they're missing the big picture
i find that most of my students come
into the classroom
uh out of the love of something they
really like and
interested to sort of do something like
that but i don't actually know that
they've spent a tremendous amount of
time thinking about how any of it is
made
and so i don't think they come with any
ticker biases i think they actually come
pretty open
to learning about that we see so much
media now that they are very versed
in all different kinds of styles and
tones and aesthetics
and they can tell you what they like and
so i spend most of my time focusing on
two things
teaching the nuts and bolts skills to
actually get the images to look like you
want
and uh pushing them to be rigorous and
how they think about
story and tone and style for their own
work
why did you write after we leave after
we leave is inspired by a couple of
different inspiration points that sort
of all converge together
the first one was a very just out of the
blue sort of uh brainstorm moment i was
sitting in traffic on wilshire boulevard
at a stoplight i can still i can picture
the exact stop that i was sitting at
and a face just appeared in my mind and
it was a man and he was looking and i
just knew implicitly
this is a man looking at his wife in the
distance and a question
came to me which was has he changed
and i didn't even know what that
question meant but i just knew that it
like i felt it in some deep emotional
way
and it started me on this journey about
asking who this character was
and when i started thinking about what
it means for a character to change
it made me realize that i had a certain
frustration
uh with a lot of mainstream filmmaking
which is about
really deeply flawed characters who
undergo a remarkable change
and get a big reward for it and i had a
lot of questions about that i realized
like
do people really change that much and do
characters like that deserve rewards
like what is the implication of those
kinds of stories
and it set me on a path to developing
the character for this movie uh
which i do think of as being a
meditation a little bit on
how much people can change and what they
get for that change
and the limits of like what a certain
kind of sort of white male protagonist
uh can achieve contrary to what i think
is sort of a dominant form of hollywood
storytelling
when did you begin writing the script i
wrote the movie i always say when obama
was still president
and people thought it was a pessimistic
take on the future
and having now gone through production
and releasing it in our current
political era
i think it's actually now sadly more
prescient uh but the truth was when i
was writing it i was
thinking about big trends in the world
and what the future might look like i
mean that's one of the beauties of
science fiction
is that it can be this way to reflect on
the present
in a different way
and it doesn't always have to be
negative i know it was at first look
kayla quinn
would would speak of that it doesn't
always have to be gloom and doom
yeah and the truth is i don't think
about the uh i don't think about the
film as being negative
i more think about it asking questions
about the implications of certain trends
now where they will go
in some ways like i actually don't think
of the film being pessimistic or
optimistic
it's more a thought experiment of what
if
what would happen and less about putting
a judgment on that
and more just exploring what might occur
and so the notion of change and if
people can change and if
they do what's the purpose why does that
intrigue you
i think that it intrigues me because
of the maybe the potential gap between
real life and the stories we tell
our stories are almost exclusively built
around a single protagonist changing
and my movie is about that too but i was
fascinated
in saying but is there a different
version of that story that i can tell
that i think evokes a little more of my
own personal feelings about
actual real life uh i'm not a pessimist
i don't think no one can change
but i do think that human change is a
strange thing and sometimes you know
we change just enough to know the limits
of ourselves
uh and i wanted to make a movie about
that sure or maybe we can change
what we do like actions or or who we
surround ourselves with
but our general core is the same you
know absolutely and i think that's a
very interesting question to ask
is uh how we judge and think about
uh a change in one's actions versus the
change inside one's head
and whether that matters or you know or
whether that's enough
you're sitting in traffic wilshire
boulevard i'm sure it was a
lovely uh la uh intersection with lots
of
commotion was this your first feature
script that you were planning to write
or had you written prior
feature scripts i had written many
feature scripts most of them i had
written
right after i got out of film school
largely with an eye tours trying to sell
them or get them set up
to be produced sort of within the studio
system
a few of which i even liked i mean some
of them i'm glad i wrote just because i
think you need to write a certain bad
script just to get to
uh a better script uh but yeah i had
been writing a lot
and with the few things that i had that
had been well received
i was still running up against the
roadblock of people saying this
this is a potentially a makeable script
but not with you as a director
you've never directed a feature no one's
going to take that risk
and so really after me leave was my
answer to that
recurring complaint i was like fine if
that's the case i'm just going to go
make my own movie
and get that one excuse out of the way i
will i will be a feature filmmaker
by making my own film and then i can
hopefully return to trying to get some
of these bigger budget things off the
ground
and these were producers that you were
pitching that were saying producers
agents um you know just i think and
never by the way in a mean way
you know i think uh appreciative of the
the sort of work that i was trying to do
and interested in the stories i wanted
to tell
but just being frank about just the
reality of who they were going to
entrust
x dollars with and that it would be a
hard fight for someone who hadn't made a
feature
which of course is sort of a catch-22
right you know like
we we talk a lot about access to the
industry and if the access point is how
come you haven't already made something
we get caught in this vicious circle
right
uh and so i just wanted to break out of
that and
for me the solution was just making a
very small budgeted film
uh that i could direct and craft in the
way i wanted
uh which again i did primarily just as a
form of self-expression
you know i made the movie not as a
career calling card primarily not as a
strategic move in hollywood i made it
because i just wanted to tell that story
uh i think the benefit is it now makes
me a director
uh in a lot more people's eyes and it
has opened more doors
but that wasn't really my my main reason
for doing it
speaking of of access i know this is
taking a little bit of a
diversion a little bit but um what what
are some of the misconceptions whether
they're from students or or just
other people in the industry about
access
and and what have you seen from going
through this process being told this
yourself that you can't do it
i think if we're specifically talking
about feature films
i think the biggest problem with access
is just that the business entirely has
changed since you know a lot of us
fell in love with movies there just are
so many fewer
smaller movies being made by the studios
and the big production companies
that i actually just think opportunities
for newer directors or less experienced
directors just aren't even there
i actually think that the a lot of that
access problem is just
they're not in the business of making
those movies that they used to give to a
younger director
they're just making these huge movies
that being said i definitely think for
sure that the overall industry has
biases against uh and they're structural
biases right they're biases that come
not from
necessarily bad intentions but there are
barriers to women to people of color for
sure
the i think the hope right is that
there's an antidote to that which is
what we can now make our own content and
i do think that that is a valid
idea that the way around the access
problem is to make stuff but i think the
funny thing these days is
i don't know the model anymore is make a
low budget film so that you can then
jump up to a you know a lower mid-budget
studio movie
because those won't even exist you know
i i think that really
i've sort of rethought how i think about
my career
i'm just going to keep making movies
like i actually don't expect there to be
this moment when all of a sudden
now i don't have to self-produce or at
least you know partially self-produce my
own movies
because i don't know that those that
that path exists anymore i really think
of making these films like i want to
make these movies and i'll make them
the career of directing movies in
hollywood there's so few films made
these days if you really think about it
that
i don't know that that's a path that one
sort of incrementally gets to
sometimes you make a film good enough on
your own that you get that lightning
strike and you can level up that big way
but i don't think there's any more
incremental steps to those big movies
anymore because i think there's nothing
in between
so when your students come to you with
questions about um
you know access are you just telling
them that the same thing basically just
don't try to like make something just so
you can get to that next level so that
someone will quote endorse you
i mean the very first thing that we talk
about at oxy
is that the skills involved with
filmmaking and with media making
we don't think of those as skills that
are exclusively for hollywood
i think we live in a world where the
ability to tell your story and express
yourself visually
is something that everyone needs to do
individuals
companies non-profits governments
cultural institutions
all of them need to do that and so i
think of this toolbox
artistically and logistically that we're
giving people in the classroom as
applying
to a huge amount of life when we talk
specifically about access to hollywood i
do tell people it's like i don't think
that
independent so i don't think that film
director is a career
i think film director is an aspiration i
think independent film director is a
calling or i wish i had a better word
than hobby because i don't think it's a
hobby
but i don't actually think it's a career
path i think it is the thing one does
you're compelled to do it
but if you really if you were to corner
even when you think of
successful independent directors and ask
them do you pay your mortgage with
filmmaking income this year
so many of them will say no and that's
just a reality and that's not a reason
to stop making movies
it's a reason to ask yourself why am i
making movies
uh if you are making movies because you
just feel compelled to do it that's the
right answer
when should a screenwriter introduce
conflict in the screenplay
i think conflict needs to emerge
organically at first oftentimes when i'm
brainstorming
writing a script i try to avoid actually
thinking about like the classic sort of
markers of structure
that we think of whether it's three act
or five act or the story circle or save
the cat any of those things
for me i just want to know as i'm
getting to know the characters and as
i'm shaping the characters i do think
that i'm consciously shaping those
characters not just letting them emerge
sort of from some you know ethereal muse
uh how are the characters different from
each other how do they see the world
different from each other
and how does that create conflict and
then how do the characters and their war
and the environment the society
themselves how do they clash
and i think that there's no timetable
for that
i think that there are some movies where
there's conflict in the very first shot
that are masterpieces and there are some
where if we're going to use a classic
definition of conflict
we're 20 minutes in before we realize
what the conflict is
i definitely don't believe in any sort
of timing formula what i do think is
you can feel artificially forced
conflict oh i just needed to have you
know these two
you know oppose each other in this scene
or that sort of thing uh for me like i'm
just much more interested in asking what
is the journey the characters on
uh and what sort of um
yeah when do they react and when did
they sort of come up against an
oppositional force
and when do they have trouble and that's
usually you know
emerges from them not a particular sort
of preset timing
and how do you continue conflict uh you
know how they just say like punish your
characters make it just horrible for
them how do you continue conflict
without
like you said being it having to be
overdone
i think the core of your idea you can
the
test of a good idea i think is does the
journey the character is set apart from
set on from the beginning
does it have enough sort of you know uh
turns of the wheel
to evolve the problems that they
encounter
uh and i think that you know a lot of
times
the difference between a short film and
a feature film is is the central
conflict
something that can be expressed in a
single moment and that's kind of the
extent of that idea
or is it an evolving topic
what were some of the biggest writing
mistakes you made in the beginning
of your screenplay writing and how did
you realize there were mistakes
i think the let me think about that it's
a good question
what are the mistakes i mean i made all
sorts of mistakes when i was starting to
write uh
but you know i think i don't necessarily
think of them as mistakes and more just
like i think it's just the process of
learning you know and and i'm happy that
i
that i was able to you know have the
time to
to just keep writing and writing and
writing things that jump to mind when i
think about like
my particular early mistakes i think one
i was a little scared of
trusting my own point of view i think i
was relying too much on the models of
screenwriting you know looking at
books on the hero's journey and
three-act structure and
and you know now you know some of the
more involved i was just i was obsessed
with those things i was trying to find
an answer in them
and at the end of the day like i do
think that they have some use but no for
me
i realize when i just let go of that and
just ask myself like just core emotional
and dramatic questions
first of all actually sometimes it would
result in stuff that actually had that
structure anyways inherent in it
and even when it didn't it still worked
so definitely like the uh sort of
avoiding
the structure i think honestly also uh
not uh outlining and spending enough
time planning
there's such a temptation to feel like
you're not getting anything done until
you type on the page
and i feel like if anything what i've
learned in every time i write a
screenplay i think i now spend
longer in the brainstorming and then
outlining phase
each time realizing that it's so easy to
think i just typed a scene like that
means i made progress but if it's not
the right scene
not the right entry to that scene not
the right characters not the right time
that time doesn't really get me anywhere
and so i'm really trying to like and
it's hard to do that it's hard to stay
in the brainstorming phase because it
can feel like oh my god i'm not making
progress
quite literally if we use page count as
like our metric of progress i wrote five
pages today
uh and i do think that that is i think
in some ways like destructive to
creativity like
sitting there at times which i i've sat
for an hour staring out the window
and had no good thought until the final
two minutes but that one idea was so
good
shapes the whole film that that hour
that the 58 minutes where i didn't think
of anything was worth that two minutes
those two minutes might be worth weeks
of writing
just to have that right sort of you know
brainstorm so for sure i think i rushed
too quickly into writing pages
uh was another mistake i made and then
lastly i really do believe
it's related to outlining i don't think
you should start writing the movie until
you know the end
uh i think the end of a movie is so
important because it should inform
everything that comes before it i think
it's
in some ways no matter whether you're
making a super clear movie or something
in biggest movie whatever the ending
is it's you know in the classic setup of
like a joke
if that's the punch line the setup has
to be right for it and i think
writing any pages before you know where
that's coming is a mistake
even if your ending is open-ended i
think you need to know you're leading to
that
and so until i know the end i won't
start writing
how do you finish a screenplay it seems
like so many people have these great
ideas and yeah i'm gonna get right to
and they tell everybody about it
but then months go by
they're at a blockage i know you said
possibly
knowing the ending i think it's hard to
finish a screenplay i really do
uh i think it's hard to write uh you
know i don't
i don't know i know so many different
writers and filmmakers people i went to
school with people i've met in the
industry
and honestly when you ask them candidly
i haven't heard any of them tell me it's
easy to finish a screenplay
for me this screenplay in particular for
after we leave
was a different process i knew that i
wanted to experiment with improvisation
and sort of bring a sort of american
indie a little bit of mumble core
to sci-fi and so i had parts of the
screenplay that i knew i was never going
to finish that i had a setup i knew the
stakes of the scene i knew where i was
going to begin where it was going to end
but i actually left some parts of the
screenplay totally open
and that was for two reasons one i was
just interested in sort of loosening up
my artistic process
uh but also i wanted to um just
try and experiment and sort of see where
this story could go
so in some ways i don't know if the
screenplay ever was finished until we
finished shooting
and so when you presented this
the script to your actors they were
fully aware that
they would really need to know your
their character absolutely you know most
of the actors on the film
people had worked with before uh and
even when they weren't you know i would
start with a conversation about the
process of the film that we were going
to make a film that was improvisatory
that was experimental we were we might
go out some days and get
one shot and that might be it we might
go out and shoot a whole scene and be
like yeah i don't know if i like that
let's try it again
the idea was we were keeping our costs
so low that we never had to make
a decision based on money that we could
make what's the coolest thing we could
do the risky thing and part of that was
improvisation with the actors
i've been on set a number of times in
other contexts where an actor had a
completely different idea about the
character in that scene and when
money is on the line and time is tight
you're just so inclined to
not sort of engage with that idea
because you're like i don't know
we're under pressure on budget i better
just do the safe thing shoot it safely
and do what exactly the script said but
when you're free when you've adopted a
model where there's less money being
spent
you're shooting you know on a different
timetable you can embrace that
you'll be like wow i never thought about
it that way let's try it let's do it
and so most of the actors were very
excited about that idea
i made a series of promises to my
collaborators sort of giving them a
little more freedom on this movie
and to the actors i always said you can
always have one more take
you know like my promise to you is i
have an idea for what i want a very
specific idea you know i didn't abandon
my directorial voice
i wrote some of the scenes you know
pretty explicitly
i knew what i wanted from the scenes but
then we always tried
things that they had in mind and some of
those things are in the film
you know and are better than the ideas
that i had so they were really open
and excited about improvising would you
say you're a planner by nature
you seem pretty i am a planner by nature
you know um
the joke about me in film school was
that when i showed up my first set
i had craft service in two boxes divided
by salty and sweet
i've never lived down salty and sweet
and this movie actually was a
very very conscious attempt to shake
that up a little bit
i used to be the kind of filmmaker who
would storyboard every single frame
and i can tell you this story i remember
showing up to the set of a web series i
was directing
i got there in the morning and i said i
know every single shot i'm going to get
and what it's going to look like
and at first i was happy about that and
i came home that night
and i had indeed gotten exactly the
shots i had imagined and they were how i
wanted them to be
and i literally almost cried because i
realized like i did not
come to l.a i did not like do this crazy
thing
to execute a shot list on time
to get competent coverage that basically
covered the story like
and i and so i made a vow to myself like
i was never going to show upset without
butterflies in my stomach again
and part of how i did that was i do plan
i do rigorously think through
the characters backstories and what they
want the visual language of the scene
the aesthetics of the whole film i think
about that all the time
but i also always want to leave space
for surprises now
i want to show up and be nervous am i
going to be able to get everything i
want
because i'm reaching for my own cool
stuff because my other collaborators
will have other ideas
and to me that's my new measure of
success if i'm nervous when i show upset
every day then i'm doing something right
and so how was that for you then to go
in with this mindset of like
i'm gonna let it go especially if you
want to make sure that every eye
is is dotted t's crossed
this the way you solve the problem of
if you have a such a strong vision of
the film but you want to have
collaborate you just need to pick your
collaborators really well
because for me i loved going to set and
and realizing that i wasn't going to be
the only person to contribute ideas
because i so trusted the instincts of my
actors
particularly my lead actor brian
silverman i can't overstate how much i
trust the instincts of my
cinematographer julie kirkwood
he's just a visual and emotional genius
uh
and so yeah i was very happy
to open up my process because what
usually happened was
people came up with great ideas
oftentimes that achieved the exact goal
i had
uh for the film and when they didn't and
it was
better i'm never gonna turn down a
better idea you know that's
why would i you know and so yeah so i i
found that
this movie is the closest i've come to
having the movie i saw in my head
be the movies on screen but ironically
it's the one where i've been the most
collaborative
and invited the most participation and
that's a lesson that i will take with me
for the rest of my life
and so what was the nights and weekends
process for shooting how long did that
last
we shot this movie over the course of
four years the plan was instituted over
the course of about six to eight months
but the idea was i was gonna get my
favorite and dearest collaborators
many of whom you know work big
professional sort of jobs
uh but i wanted to be able to shoot
without the pressure of like okay we can
only do it in seven days because the
only time anyone's free
instead we said okay let's buy the
camera we bought a dslr
um let's embrace a method of shooting
where when we just happen to be free we
go out and we shoot a piece of the movie
and in doing so we will never be
choosing the safe camera angle that
captures all the actions that we can get
we can at least get the editing room no
there's no cost to us failing on a
particular day we're not in the middle
of this intense
you know compressed shoot so we shot on
nights and weekends there were days in
which we showed up to set
at seven in the morning shot one shot
everyone went off to their jobs
there were other time periods where for
three days straight you know we shot
scenes
because we all happen to have time free
and the real there were two big benefits
from that one like i said just taking
the pressure off of the
system which allowed us to be more
experimental more free
but also i have never learned as much
during the making of a film
and still be able to apply it to the
film you know every time you make a
project you learn something
but what was beautiful about shooting
incrementally was i grew as a filmmaker
and i could apply that to this film and
so this film got better because i was
making the film that way
four years do you mind if i ask the
budget we made we got the film
shot and in the can for about fifteen or
sixteen thousand dollars
and then we had about fifteen thousand
dollars in post uh to sort of get it
finished so
around thirty thousand dollars i when i
say that number though i also like to
say
with a lot of favors um you know it was
a sag movie so uh we we did i did pay
the actors through the sag system
most of my key crew worked for free or
for
very below their rate and honestly
everyone was super generous with their
time
uh in a way that was very gratifying to
me they just loved the project
and i was allowing people to have more
freedom and more input than they
got in their normal industry sort of job
and i think that's part of what inspired
them to come work for me the thing i
love about that number about the fact
that we made it for 30 000
is like i don't think it's ever easy to
make a movie
and i think even the ability to muster
thirty thousand dollars half of which i
got through
through kickstarter uh even the ability
to do that is a privilege you know
i don't think that means i i realize
very well that doesn't mean even
that everyone can do that but thirty
thousand dollars is so much less than
what a big movie
costs in hollywood and i want that to be
a message that
we can make different sci-fi movies and
different genre movies
uh that address more niche ideas or more
quirky ideas uh
and they're more personal because not as
much money's on the line
do you think hollywood movies are junk
food or are they a necessary part of
culture media i like a wide range of
movies like i
love big blockbuster films and i like
obscure black and white documentaries
you know i really like it like at all
so for me yeah i'm not someone who i
think wants to call
any particular genre kind of movie as
not being cinema or
as you know being junk food but what i
am interested in is making sure that
it's like a diverse
palette on the you know a diverse feast
i the only time i'm upset is when i feel
like only one kind of movie is just
dominating the entire conversation
it's all we can see it's all we can talk
about then i have misgivings and i do
feel that way a little bit about
sci-fi when i was a kid i would have
killed have
any sci-fi movie in a theater and it's
so funny to now like have inherited the
earth like
the biggest movies in the world are star
wars and star trek and all the marvel
movies comic books sci-fi
and i love that on the one hand but i
also have a really strong feeling that
those movies are surprisingly monolithic
they are
spectacle action movies with a
speculative element
and their main difference is how comedic
they are uh and i actually like a lot of
them
i think jj abrams star trek movie is a
brilliant movie i think thor ragnarok is
a very entertaining film
but i also want there to be more
children of men you know
like uh and so i think that my only push
is i don't want to push anybody out of
the conversation
i just want there to be more people in
do you feel that stuff like the twilight
zone is still
is still prevalent today in terms of
sort of these raw stories with very few
special effects but
the same general idea there is
a movement of indie sci-fi it predates
my film for sure
that i think is out there the question
of how you are finding it i think is the
second question but i think if you look
at
uh shane carruth and gareth edwards like
uh
and you know and honestly you know a
whole bunch of filmmakers working in
asia and europe and in africa like you
will see
a huge movement of indie sci-fi it's
there it's not that it doesn't exist i
think the challenge it faces
is reaching an audience and that's
something i'd like to see more of is
having those films sort of you know be
seen more
do you think that indie filmmakers are
afraid of sci-fi because they feel like
they can't do it on this large scale
indie filmmakers are for i for sure i
think afraid of sci-fi
because i think there's still this
dominant messaging that
a vfx film must cost a million dollars
and i don't even mean that as an
exaggeration i think people see the
stuff in my phone and they they think
like
did that cost a million dollars and my
message really is no there's been such a
revolution
in personal computing in software that
while it's not easy it is very possible
uh to make visual effects films on indie
film budgets
but i don't think surprisingly even
though i think we are a decade into this
movement
i still don't think enough independent
filmmakers realize
they can dream in this way they can be
creative in this way through genres like
horror and sci-fi
and fantasy it can happen
i think you have to have the idea for it
and then if you have the idea there are
a lot of ways to accomplish that idea
now
and then that being said with your film
after we leave you wanted to make sure
that the sci-fi was in the background
and that the the story the emotion of
the character was in the beginning and
that was my choice like part of my
artistic
agenda was to say i think it's
interesting to
focus on character and conflict and the
big sort of questions
through a future lens but i think what's
great about this revolution
in vfx and in digital you know cameras
and all that sort of stuff
is that another filmmaker might come
along and be like you know what i want
to make
an interface vfx spectacle that even
that can happen now and i wish more
people would do that
particularly i'm excited about women
filmmakers and people of color
filmmakers who are
just you know deciding yeah i can do
this i can tell a sci-fi story or a
fantasy story
uh i can't get enough of that did you
write differently knowing that you would
be using visual effects
is there a different sort of language
you're using depending on the genre of
a film you're making one of my goals for
this project was to
not uh do anything because of the visual
effects to not alter the process because
of that
and part of the workflow that my brother
and i developed when we knew we were
going to do this sci-fi movie was
from the writing phase and the shooting
phase i wanted to treat it like it was a
totally realist movie
and make it in the way that i would make
it it was just a normal drama present
day set
and the reason i can do that is just
because of the advances in visual
effects technology
the fact that we don't have to lock off
the camera anymore that we don't need
millions of dollars to do each shot
that you know the fact that we can you
can pre-visualize it even as an indie
filmmaker
so no i approached the movie uh i didn't
think about the visual effects at all
uh when the first draft in the second
draft for sure i went through and there
were a few moments where i thought
that's probably too expensive for me to
do or too time consuming but
that was more but you do that in any
screenplay even when it's not visual
effects
oh i just wrote a set piece in dodger
stadium if it's a little bit difficult i
probably should take that out so i did
some of that
but no actually one of my like big big
goals was to
not treat this in the way that hollywood
treats a visual effects project which i
think sometimes makes it somehow
different
i wanted to just write a drama shoot it
like i was shooting a drama
uh and have the future be in it and
thankfully my brother and i sort of
worked out a system that allowed that to
happen
yeah i heard you say in another
interview with us by the way she was a
great interviewer she talked
about you said uh moral moral dilemma in
the beginning
or in the forefront and visual effects
in the background we had a mantra on set
which was
with very few exceptions but our mantra
was if the first thing the audience is
looking at is a visual effect
we're doing something wrong that i
really wanted the character and the
story and yes jack's moral dilemma
that's what i should be looking at and
if because it's a sci-fi movie we do
need to evoke a future los angeles
and it's about you know interstellar
migration so we do need rockets that go
there
those will all be there but the movie is
not sort of always focused on that
and i think to go one step further i was
really trying to make a movie that felt
like it was shot in the time period
i often sort of say that if you watch a
movie from like the 1950s
very rarely is the camera person when
the just a normal 40s or 50s car goes by
is there a shot that's like whoa look at
that car because it's normal it's a fact
of life
but for some reason in our current like
blockbuster vernacular the camera is
almost always in awe i think it's kind
of just trying to show like look at that
look at that
but instead i wanted you know even in my
movie when the rockets launch
there's no huge punch in on the rockets
a tight close-up there's no
amazing kinetic shot it's just the
camera pans slightly and then just comes
back
because my mind was i want a future
camera operator to be operating that
camera
and think yeah rockets okay back to this
you know like i want it to feel like
that it was made in the time period
because again my goal was
not to have this vfx spectacle where
everyone just sort of fetishized the vfx
i want to tell story in the future but
it's the story
not the future that was sort of you know
most important
what do you see that your students
wanting to tell like what really moves
them
my students are very interested in
seeing themselves reflected on screen
and that means i think some of the
obvious topics we think about today i do
think it means that
they want to see more women characters
on screen and more complex women they
want to see
you know underrepresented groups on
screen different identities
but also i think they just want to see
their mindset and their
feelings i think that they feel like uh
there is a dominant representation of
life that doesn't actually sync up with
their own experience
that it's a little bit out of date that
you know people 10 20 30 years older
than them are primarily telling stories
older than them and so their real desire
seems to be to see a reflection of their
lived experience on screen
i mean i think back to that's this is a
john hughes film
pretty in pink you know and even though
i liked the film i didn't
see myself represented there did you
feel that growing up
i i felt that in many ways like for sure
as a kid growing up who's
half south asian half white i didn't see
anybody on screen who looked like me
uh and i used to look like me as sort of
a stand-in for a broad set of concerns
like
who came from a family like mine who who
you know
fought in a way like i did who had
experiences in life the way i did
that was certainly just really lacking
from movies when i was growing up
uh but secondly honestly like
i was also just i you know i didn't feel
like i fitted in so many ways
and i watched high school movies that
had tropes that just didn't match up
with my life
i watched action movies where the stakes
just didn't seem to match up with my
life you know and so
uh yeah there was a lot lacking one of
the things that i think is also kind of
magical is
how many movies really resonated with me
you know
one of the nice things about being from
multicultural background is i think i
in some ways can sometimes have it both
ways i was probably
easier for me than other people uh to
just
identify with lots of different kinds of
protagonists and lots of different kinds
of stories
because of how many of these i've been
exposed to just in my life in general
so was there one character that even
though maybe
different life circumstances but you
just felt really just uh resonated with
you you felt a kinship
hmm that's a very good question i like
that one when you think
i think that there when i i really
remember
watching um star wars and
realizing luke skywalker he's basically
a kid like
me you know like he's older than me when
i you know uh when i was watching me but
like
i do remember thinking like it's so
interesting that the hero of this movie
is not a badass you know like he's
actually just like learning about the
world and i think that's one of the
things i think is like under sort of
realized about that movie that i mean
han solo is an amazing character he's
awesome
he's not the main character of that
movie though you know the main character
is like you know a character where most
of the film
is just trying to catch up with what's
going on in the world
and not realizing the role he plays in
and i like that a lot
in the four years you were making after
we leave how are you balancing
your professor at occidental college
here in los angeles or eagle rock
and you have a family you have children
how are you balancing all that
that's a lot the truth is i think that
that balance is never perfect
i often joke that what i think doesn't
get talked about enough
uh is that the stage of life that i'm in
right now is i don't know that i do
anything as well as i wish that i could
but i'm just trying to get all of it to
at least be pretty good uh
being a dad being a professor being a
husband being a filmmaker
they all have their demands every one of
them is awesome i wouldn't give up
any of them uh but no for sure making
this movie is one of the most difficult
things i've ever done
and i don't say that actually looking
for pity but more like i think there
just should be a more candid
acknowledgement
of how hard it is to balance those
things uh you know
for part of this movie i was like i was
a part-time professor a part-time
stay-at-home dad
and trying to make a feature and then um
you know now i'm a
full professor a full-time professor at
occidental and uh you know i have two
kids now instead of one when i started
um and for sure yeah like that balance
is difficult
in so many ways in terms of just time
when can you get free to do it
uh in terms of just resources uh you
know those are things there's just
spending money and
and that sort of stuff and then more
generally the the hardest one i find is
the shift in mindset
that if i were to really encapsulate the
phase of life i'm in right now it's
having to shift gears and sort of take
off different hats and put different
hats on with no real transition points
so to go from
dad to professor to filmmaker to dad to
you know like
around that uh there's no mental space
to sort of flip over and i've just
accepted i think i just
where it where i am right now uh and i
think there's this image of like
filmmaking that is
almost like a divorce from the rest of
life but again
you know i think that this is the
reality of independent cinema
and every filmmaker i know knows this i
actually think we should talk about it
more
which is to say if you are feeling like
uh
man it's really hard to like you know
pack that lunch for the kid
and then like go to your job in my case
like teach this lesson correctly
and then make it to set on time and
shoot this shot having remembered
everything you needed
and being in a state of mind to be
creative if you're like that's difficult
i want to say like yeah
it is difficult and i don't know who
we're kidding if we're saying it's not
uh and and and to me like and that's
fine like i think that like
that struggle is a reality and so i'm
just trying to
maximize it and optimize it but i don't
think it's going to go away
yeah i see too much of this mindset of
like i got this and i can tell you know
i
no this doesn't you know and i wish
sometimes people were more transparent
with
no this is really tough and yeah i don't
know if i do have it
but i'm still going to show up you know
and i think it's important to
acknowledge that again
because i think
it's an the amount of time you can
devote to filmmaking i do think
becomes a representation of an amount of
privilege that you have and i think it
is important for us to recognize by the
way that it is actually
harder for different people to get that
half a day to even shoot a scene that
i'm talking you know like i'm talking
about
or to get an hour to do that and that
big societal things like that are part
of the reason
for the representation gap in behind the
camera and in front of the camera
and that's why it's hard to address
these things you know that it can't just
be oh open up our application process or
we'll open up our
you know how receptive we are to other
ideas that's awesome
but you can have removed a lot of
barriers to entry
and still larger sort of structural
problems in like
society can be altering who even
tries to step through those doors that's
a really good point i think that
relates to interning as well even though
you know there's a lot of backlash about
interning the entire industry is like i
think
built on this idea of well we have all
these dreamers and the ones that are the
most passionate they'll come and put in
the time
and i have to be honest again i don't
say this to have any judgment against
any individual who says that but i think
it's reflective
of a structural bias that
if you have a system where the measure
of like whether someone is deserving is
they prove it to you by how much time
they put in that is equivalent to saying
your system is structurally biased
against
people who for whom time is a greater
resource a harder to find resource
and that's gonna be women people of
color
people of lower income and so we have to
be careful about i think it's always
important to judge
passion and to see who's serious about
what they want to do
but measuring that through certain
metrics that we've used in the past
i do think contributes to the
homogeneity of the industry
single moms single dads exactly and even
if they do have time are they gonna be
so tired
exactly that they can't finish it yeah i
think that's one thing that
you don't think about when you're
younger is oh yeah i can totally do this
and i can balance all this stuff
you don't realize how tired you're going
to be and and
you can't think clearly you know and i
think that's um
yeah anyway that's another video what
are some of your cardinal rules of
filmmaking that you actually ended up
breaking
while on set so you knew you had certain
things you like i think you said
don't don't write a scene for something
that you can't budget there's some
huge you know subway station or whatever
that you can't film in
i definitely believe that you should be
practical with what you can actually
achieve
and i thought i was being careful for
example about only picking locations
that i knew i could get
but for sure towards the end of the
shooting i had this one scene that i
could never take off my checklist to do
which was
i had written a scene that takes place
in this bureaucratic visa office a sort
of dmv for the future
and i wrote this scene and i just every
time i thought about
oh cheating it or moving it to a
different kind of location or being more
modest i just got sad
but then to actually find a place that
would be full of enough people and
look like an institutional setting was
super difficult and i kept thinking to
myself like why did i get myself into
this
dilemma and sure enough that was the
last scene we shot we just like right up
to the end i just couldn't figure out
how to do it
and honestly when the movie was done we
shot half that scene in a way that
i'm glad it worked out but was risky we
walked into a dmv sat down and shot
and we get kicked out in about 15
minutes but that 15 minutes it's in the
movie
and then the second half of it we did
sort of build something uh
sort of uh in a sort of soundstage way
very cheaply
but yeah i definitely broke the rule of
you know think about your locations but
i'm glad that i did i think that rule of
like being modest about locations
leads to honestly films that are like
not as interesting as they should be
i get why the advice often is oh make a
contained feature a one room feature or
one place feature in
that is a practical bit of advice but i
don't know like it
it leads to a certain kind of
storytelling and so i was very
interested in being like i actually
think i can make
a journey across los angeles as a movie
in all these different locations and
still keep it cheaply
uh but yeah that one that dmv at the end
kind of got me so that was one rule that
i broke
uh the other rule that i that i think
that i i i sometimes would break is
even as much as i was embracing the idea
of always switching out the most
interesting camera angle
and the you know like the most quirky
performance moment
there were certainly times where i was
tired the sun was going down
and i could feel that voice being like
just make a safe choice and be done
just make a safe choice and get out of
here on time and i'm sure that there are
times that i did that a little bit you
know and i think
my aspiration every film out is to do
that less and less
directing for visual effects how is that
different from directing let's just say
and coming of age drama for me
my goal was to have the onset directing
process be
no different when it comes to visual
effects than my normal process
for me the change is all in
pre-production uh i wanted to be able to
show up on set
and not have to change i didn't want to
have to block the actors any more than i
normally would be inclined to
i didn't want to have to be limited to
my camera angles anymore that i would
normally be
and so the solution to that was sitting
down with my brother
uh who's a visual effects artist and
asking him okay what's possible and
what's not
within those constraints tell me all
things we can do that don't require me
to lock off the camera
have the actors hit precise blocking
marks or limit
my frame and once i knew the things i
could do those are the things i put in
the movie
because i didn't want to be in a
situation where i had to like bend the
movie to that process
on set because again like i feel like
the point of a movie is the story and
the characters
and that's what the process should be
about in pre-production i think we
there's a lot more pre-visualization
though for sure there is a version of
this movie which is just
me and my dp julie kirkwood shooting
each other on our iphones
doing all the shots and then showing it
to my brother and asking them can you
composite this in here
we got to get this to work out over here
we could probably cut together
a shot by shot remake of the movie which
is just starring me or julie
on little iphone footage but that was
our process for both
that was our creative process for
developing a visual language but also
for planning the visual effects
i could just shoot it on my phone go to
my brother if we do this can you put
this in the background can this be in
the foreground we'll be able to
rotoscope that all that kind of stuff
and he would say yes or no and then that
would influence what i would then try to
do on set
what was the biggest visual effect you
used what scene was that
uh the two biggest ones are the the
second or third shot in the movie is
uh rockets launching sort of and we see
them sort of in the distance but
just getting doing a shot that involved
you know photo realistic rockets you
know rising over the horizon was
uh just very time consuming but all in
post shooting it was very very easy
uh on set ironically the thing we spent
the longest time doing was a very simple
shot of just someone using a touchscreen
um but making sure that with reflections
and uh and lighting that we were going
to be able to successfully you know
create a space machine you know there's
a touchscreen and there's a hand there's
a space in between when you delay and
the visual effects
just working that out was the hardest
shot even though it's one of the most
simple seeming shots in the movie
um but getting that right was was a
challenge for sure
and how did you do that like what were
some of the in the end you know we tried
a lot of different ways like i
i was i was convinced it was gonna be
the one green screen shot in the movie
either we had a skewed all green screens
just in favor of other forms of working
uh but in the end we
i just we just frame by frame rotoscoped
it um and
uh and the result was great and it
worked out just fine
uh but it was more like i was almost
nervous to leave it to that and so i
spent time trying to shoot alternates
but in the end my brother was right i
should just stuck with the process he
recommended
which would have actually been not doing
anything out of ordinary just have the
actor do the gestures that i planned out
which we had mapped out
and we would have been done in half the
time but i was just nervous and so we
tried to do a green screen version
hate it when the brother's right i know
so off screen i asked will you be
working on a new movie and i think you
said absolutely yes do you plan to have
it be
a four-year process knowing that you
have this new motto is sort of like
we're gonna just be free and we're gonna
go in i'm not gonna over plan it
uh i very much hope to continue the
process i started with after we leave
on my next movie i do hope to do it
quicker than that though
i don't want to go out with a low budget
and try to emulate the classic like are
we going to shoot with indie feature in
12 days i still don't believe in that i
still think that leads to
making safe choices that aren't as
interesting creatively and putting too
much pressure on each moment
but i would like to shoot it in quicker
than four years and i think really the
solution for that is i think having done
it once
i've learned a lot about what moments
that allow for creativity are really
worth it and what we're just sort of
experiments even in process
so my hope is yeah i think that if i go
out make another low budget feature
i'd like to do it in this period of a
couple of months um
in terms of the shooting and then in
post it really would depend on whether
or not it's a visual effect movie or not
um but yeah i think that there is still
a middle ground between the classic
like sort of compressed schedule of an
indie shoot and the four years of
knights weekends that i took to make
this movie
i'm hoping there's some middle ground in
the two to three month range
are you already writing the script i
have a couple of scripts that i'm
writing um
and they're of different budget levels
you know one of the goals that after we
leave was to hope that
having made this one movie which i think
visually looks more expensive than it
cost
that that will help me uh get funding
for a larger project
but i'm also trying to write just
another complete micro budget project
again like my goal is like i don't want
to go back to the
place where i'm just waiting for other
people to make a movie
uh and i'm just gonna keep making films
where do you balance your time writing
i know you said pages are not like your
main objective but
uh i find it challenging to write
regularly i think writing regularly is
super important but my life is just not
built that way
so for me i try to just schedule out at
least once a week where i just sit down
and just brainstorm
and and again focusing much more on just
like the ideas
like just thinking like is this the
actual right idea for the story is this
the right story to tell based on that
idea
uh and when i really answer those
questions then i can set aside a block
of time a couple of days
to just really go to town and write
pages i find the pages come really
quickly if the ideas are right
so for me it's just about creating that
mental space of
an hour where my phone's off and i don't
have you know i don't have a meeting
with a
a student or a professor i don't have to
pick up my kids from school yet like
some period of time where it's like all
right my brain can just free associate
trying to build that time in i think is
the most important time and then it's
very easy for me to schedule writing
pages i can write pages
like 15 minutes you know pieces if i
know what i'm supposed to be writing
will it be another sci-fi with like a
major moral dilemma
it would i i would be surprised if my
next movie is not a genre movie
um the couple of ideas that i'm kicking
right now are all genre films and not
all sci-fi
but i really i love like what genre
allows you to do i think it
leads to so much like visual freedom you
can do so many interesting aesthetic
things
in fantasy and horror and sci-fi uh and
i think it's also a really
nice way to address big issues for sure
um
but i don't know i mean i i think that
i'm my ideas really at their core
start from just some sort of emotional
image or idea that grabs me
and they kind of build out from that
through observation just being out
yeah i think they come from observation
and reflection you know like seeing
something in the world
and thinking about how it makes me feel
and then oftentimes
hypothesizing from that or extrapolating
from that into a sort of genre story
what's the biggest mistake a filmmaker
can make the biggest mistake is a very
understandable mistake
that a filmmaker can make which is i
think to
to to make a film uh that
where you're not saying anything and
when i say say something i don't
actually think it has to be profound
or that it has to be serious but i think
that
it's the the barrier to entry of just
making an image on screen has lowered
right with digital cameras and so you
can create imagery
uh and i think a mistake that a lot of
us can make is it's easier to do that
and but is there any reason for us to do
that to make the thing
so like my like real threshold is like i
think at this point
especially i thought because independent
cinema is not a high-paying career
i only want to make movies that wouldn't
exist if i wasn't here in the world
in other words what is the film that
only i would make i think as long as i'm
doing that
i've cleared the initial sort of uh you
know like uh
potential mistakes the filmmaker can
make uh and so something i tell my
students something i tell other
filmmakers
and i don't mean to say that you have to
make a holy original film but you know
what is something that comes from you it
doesn't have to be biographical
it doesn't have to be specifically about
you know your exact identity
but just your point of view your take
your feeling
as long as you're putting that into a
movie i think that's a reason to make a
film
and how does the filmmaker do it without
beating the audience over
the head with a message because you know
how so many oh a message yeah we're
going to stay away from that
distributors don't want that
because it's too biased
i think if if the if your primary front
and center goal for making a movie is a
message
uh a movie may not be the right format
um i always tell people like
a really great infographic is a pretty
great way to get out a message uh
a really great documentary sometimes a
way to get out a message uh
a you know 2000 word medium
post might be a great way to get out a
message for me with
film i do think that film absolutely
engages with the world and can have
messages in it but at least for me like
i can't start from that point i i don't
know i don't get how to make a movie
that's like good and interesting to
watch
moment to moment if the message is the
only reason you're making it
yeah i always love these people with all
the bumper stickers on the back of their
car and i'm always like
i want to read them all i want to know
there's like messages in here you know
and there's like
a general like bias to what they're
driving around trying to say
and i find it very interesting and you
know not just the you know
my dog is smarter than your honors dude
but but ones where there's like wow i
didn't yeah i've never seen that one
before
and then what my favorite one was before
you change the system you have to become
part of the system
that was my favorite one that i saw and
then i realized like wow
that's a light they're right yeah really
yeah that's so
just a side note there but what's been
the hardest part
of filmmaking for you to learn the
hardest part has been for me to
learn to to give up some of my
moment-to-moment control
and to realize that in doing that i
actually gain artistic control
i came to filmmaking i think from the
visual side and i thought that when i
started filmmaking
editing would be my favorite part of the
process where it's just me and i can
make every decision
and for a while it was and now my
favorite part is being on set
with an amazing cinematographer with
amazing actors
and being open to what that process
yields
and it's been a hard journey because it
felt like i was giving up directorial
vision at first because frankly
i think i had a misunderstanding of what
like directorial vision is i think i
thought it was
oh i'm going to micromanage every single
detail and what i've really come to
realize is that if i know
very clearly what i want what i want the
audience to feel what the point of the
movie is
if i know that and i can communicate it
then
i can actually delegate a surprising
amount of work and i will literally
get that thing i wanted because people
who know the point and know the goal
but then have space to sort of do their
own work they produce excellent work
and if you communicate well it is work
entirely in sync with what you wanted
and then there's the flip side of
someone who's just too loose with
everything and i've seen a lot of
really brilliant creative people like
that but they never ran themselves in
and they never finished things
so how is it for you to to know that you
have the opposite problem
and just see you know are you sort of in
awe sometimes of some of these messy
creative folks
or does i mean do you sort of see the
poll you know how
they say every polar opposite is
actually there's like a lot of
similarities here
i mean i i love
sort of seeing other filmmakers process
for making stuff and then one of the
ironies of being a director
is you spend very little time getting to
see other people direct
you know i'm so envious of actors
sometimes who get to go from product to
project and just see all these different
approaches
yeah i feel like i've learned from so
many different kinds of directors from
the ones that are just completely no
plan
no stuff i've learned cautionary tales
but honestly in there a little bit of
like
there's something that comes out of that
freedom and for sure even from the over
prescribed the hitchcockian storyboard
everything i've learned something too
uh all of it to me seems like there are
lessons good and bad in there
uh and i think i'm always sort of you
know adjusting as i go
do you see your students being planners
or are they more like
hey man let's just get a camera and
shoot we'll figure the story out when
we're there
in general i think that uh the students
that i interact with
um through no fault of their own i think
underestimate
uh the level of planning required to use
even our seemingly accessible digital
cameras
you know we they're growing up in an era
where they can take their phone out and
press record and get video
seamlessly without any real thought
right i don't mean like intention but
just like it's just easy to do
and so i think they go through a
learning curve that's perfectly
understandable of
realizing that even with a dslr which is
a relatively easy to operate
piece of machinery there are a lot of
things you have to pay attention to to
get it to come out right
uh and you know just literally like you
know with the f-stop and the expo
in the you know f-stop and exposure and
the iso and the resolution
and uh that making them go through those
steps so the images are what they want
uh is one of the big things that i sort
of focus on
do you think having access to too much
information hurts people because you
know just think about gen xers
we i craved all that and there wasn't
really a place except for going like
to the library and looking on microfiche
or something but i wonder if it almost
hurts
people nowadays because there's just an
overabundance of it
yeah it's an interesting question to ask
like how does
just the amount of uh information and
uh and perspectives and advice and
technology that we that are flowing into
how does that affect the creative
process uh
because in some ways i think of the
creative process of being a very
solitary
quiet thing for me that i'm at my most
creative when i built a bubble even if
it's for a few minutes
to just think in isolation that being
said i do think all that stuff is
fuel for the process and
yeah i'm kind of excited you know one of
the things when i first fell in love
with instagram it was just the ability
to see
photos of people's lives all over the
world and undoubtedly
that influenced me as an artist you know
and and
and so as much as like there are times
which i feel like oh my gosh like the
news and social media
and you know everything else overwhelms
and is like a sort of a certain amount
of like background noise that is
distracting
i also have to believe that it is um and
i do believe
that is also enriching my life
experience and i think anything that
enriches my life experience
uh sort of has a result creatively
so so with with let's say gen y or gen z
just having access to so much
information being able to just
ask a question and get so many different
answers back that you feel that's
that's helpful or or does it almost harm
the creative process because now there's
too much agenda
there's two there's too many voices you
know answering
i i really this is a really big question
but
i'm actually really excited to see what
kind of filmmakers
like the the next generation what
they're gonna do because of
yeah how they're growing up as they're
growing up first of all you know the
thing they watch more than anything is
long-form serialized content how is that
going to impact the kind of stories they
choose to tell
i fell in movies through movies like my
favorite things when i was growing
up were 90 minutes two hours uh
invariably when i asked them many of
them their favorite thing
is a television show or a streaming show
or if it is movies it'll be something
like the marvel cinematic universe which
is also a form of serialized
storytelling so i'm super excited to see
how does that impact them i am super
excited to also see
what do they choose they choose to make
movies and other kinds of you know audio
visual content
what do they do given that they grew up
with so many other things to do in their
lives you know like social media and
video games and interactive like
how will that influence the few of them
who choose to do
what we might think of as filmmaking in
the future i'm just really excited about
it like i just love the idea of
contemplating
how each generation of artists is
undoubtedly shaped by the time they grew
up in right
and yeah i don't have a lot of pessimism
or a lot of complaints like i'm just
more just excited to see what happens
is it interesting because it's halloween
time as we shoot this interview and
going to all these different um
halloween stores just how many you know
stranger things all these
costumes yeah and and and cool like
halloween gadgets are inspired by some
of these shows and
i guess that same thing was around i
know e.t there was a lot of you know i
had one little burger king elliot doll
and different things
um but but it just seems like now it's
it's even more
like it's there's a thirst for it yeah
and i think that you know the
the like a lot of sort of people growing
up today
like they are growing up in the in the
era of
our media is not just on screen right it
is expanding out to you know there's a
star wars
part of disneyland and there are
halloween costumes for stranger things
and there are novelizations and podcasts
and you know branded content uh and
i think that you could obviously look at
that in a cynical way or a commercial
way but i think what's exciting about it
is
it's a generation of artists who are
growing up with the stories they love
they can engage with in so many
different ways you know
for me i was just starved for content
like just waiting for like the next star
trek movie to come out you know like
and the fact that they have this ongoing
relationship with the things they love
i'm i wish i knew what it was like to
grow up like that i'm sure there will
create differences
uh but it doesn't seem like a pro econ
it just seems like just a really
interesting difference and i'm curious
to see what happens because of it
what's the reality of film distribution
for independent filmmakers
i think film distribution is the part of
the equation
that has been the least revolutionized
uh to the benefit of filmmakers
there's a lot of talk about we think we
know and we know inherently like
digital cameras changed the game they
made it easier to shoot something
digital editing made it easier to do
post and of course theoretically
we have these platforms you know youtube
being the best example that
theoretically reach everyone but the
real truth is like to
that so much content put on those
platforms
while theoretically accessible to
billions of people is not actually
watched
uh and and i think that like that's
actually one of the sort of like uh
facts that is i think we're not being
honest enough about
and there are lots of reasons that
content doesn't find an audience
sometimes it's quality but honestly i
think part of it is
that we still despite like the rosie
rhetoric i think we're
still not good enough at connecting the
particular audience no matter how small
but a distributed audience with content
they would like i think it's very hard
to do that because
despite all the benefits of like
egalitarianism in in filmmaking
the downside is there's just so much
stuff that it's hard to find stuff that
you like
they're i mean i'm sort of convinced
that out there right now and there are
films that could be in my top 25 films
of all time
that i don't even know exist and that
sort of pains me you know like the thing
like that's probably true
uh and and so yeah so i think that
as i you know this is my first feature
that i've made and having made a feature
and now contemplated oh yeah i got to
put this out into the world
you know i you know my phone was just
acquired my assumption is they will end
up on a major distribution platform
and there was a time in my life when i
thought if my film's on amazon
i got it made but what's so crazy is
there's a world in which you can even be
on amazon and be on netflix
and still know when to see your movie
you know uh because
did it have a big enough was it featured
probably on the main page
was the thumbnail the right one i still
think we're trying to figure all that
out
uh and i do hope that like uh
people who are interested in the art of
filmmaking uh
uh are devoting time to thinking about
how to solve these problems for sure
there are people thinking about commerce
they're trying to maximize revenue
but it would be great to have some of
you know some people who are informed
with algorithms and with
you know uh sort of user choice to think
about
how do we improve the connection between
filmmakers and their audience
do you have any thoughts on expectations
once your film is out there
you waited all this time and you know we
always think
one thing is going to look like this
when it happens and then it doesn't and
when i was in film school one of my
professors gave me this just really
great piece of advice
and it was he said remember what your
goal for the film was
when you get all at the end and you see
the response and what he meant by that
was
i think you know if you have to make a
comedy and you get to the end of the
road
and people laugh like it's so clear that
you achieve what you wanted to achieve
uh he was speaking to me though because
i was making
unsettling dramas and he was like what
you want to happen is
the film screens and everyone just
uprisingly shouts and screams and claps
but if the lights come up and everyone
is sitting in stunned silence
remember that that's your success um and
what i took from that was the idea of
like to really think about okay
yeah what are my expectations that are
appropriate for the movie
separate from just our general desire
that would think we all wish everything
we did would be just greeted by
unanimous applause
uh but also i think there's an
explanation in terms of like the the
total reach of the movie like
i uh i think if you are making a movie
solely
to get a response from the audience uh
these days there's just so much out
there that you're just almost 100
guaranteed to be disappointed
because there's just everyone's
attention is so fragmented
i made my movie hoping that some people
would watch it and then its artistic
point of view would resonate with them
and it would evoke emotions in them
and then put thought and make them think
about certain things and so
what i sort of focus on is
trying to do the best i can to reach
those people and after that
if they like it if they don't like it if
it does move them i'm interested of
course in that result
but it isn't my primary sort of
expectation for the project i think
mostly i
made a form of self-expression i tried
to make it the best i could and i'm
trying very hard to get it out to be
possible to be seen
and then after that i think i actually
don't have a lot of expectations
and do you think you do you pass that on
to your students knowing that you know
you had a professor tell you that
and i do i actually use that anecdote
every time i tell my students like
remember what success will look like for
your film
you know and and really because we're
all biased by the end i always say like
literally write down on a piece of paper
before you even shoot the film
what would success look like for this
film you know if i'm making a
a ambiguous difficult edgy movie
if half the audience is mad at me that
might be what i intended to do
now it might feel bad when you get there
but just to remind yourself that's what
you set out to do you know
um so i actually literally tell them
that um but i also tell them like i
i actually think that thinking about
overall audience response to the
movie as a whole is very rarely
creatively fruitful
i think thinking by moment is very
important like i i tell my
i tell people all the time when you're
directing just ask yourself over and
over again
what do i want the audience to know and
feel at this exact moment
and then make your camera choices about
that make your acting choices
your sound choices what do i need the
audience to know and to feel
but that's less about hoping for a
response and more being like what do i
want to tell them or make them think
about
and that's on a micro level that's super
important but on a big level i tell them
all the time like
you can't be focused on like what the
overall reception is going to be
it's hard to predict um and
uh and i don't think it's the reason to
make a movie
what's the biggest obstacle you faced
and what was your take away from it
despite the fact that i thought that i
designed a process that would allow me
to escape some of the pressures of
of filmmaking in terms of like being
more open to improv improvising or
chasing that a crazy idea i thought that
i built this perfect system where i
would never worry about time i'd never
worry about money
the truth is even making moving for as
little money as we did
and even making it in a way that was
very open to like not having time
pressure
there were still times where i felt that
you know i still felt the pressure of
it's just hard to make a movie and
there's so many moving parts
and invariably things go wrong and so
yeah i think that i just i just acutely
felt that even
when i was constantly trying to escape
it it's a hard process
to get right and it's a hard process to
sort of be artistically open and
creative during the entire time
and then does that go back to sort of
that same mantra of just we're just
gonna show up and shoot
and we're just gonna hold loosely to
some of the stuff yeah i mean i think
that i
um i mean i think i was always very
clear on like
the overall point of the movie the
overall arc of the movie but it i did it
did tell i had to psych myself up
sometimes
to once again jump off the cliff you
know to say okay yesterday didn't go
great
like we tried to improvise something or
i had a great camera idea that just
flopped
you know um and to remember like that's
part of the plan
and to be as bold today as i was
yesterday to sort of try to erase the
memory of the previous day's failure
um and and and also when i had a success
to really hold on to this just be like
see that's why it's worth
being a little crazy sometimes like that
was a moment i never would have gotten
uh i think just keeping that mental sort
of like game like i'm always gonna take
risks
embrace the butterflies in your stomach
just keep doing that
when you were in film school what were
some of the things the teachers did that
you said you know what this really works
for me and if i ever become a teacher i
want to emulate that
and then on the reverse that it sort of
shuts you down
one of the most important things that
happened to me in film school was i had
a professor
who introduced me to the idea that art
could be about process
not result and he showed a series of
experimental films and honestly even
narrative films
they were built around a way of working
or an approach or a system
and the idea that you could do that and
then be open to the result
and i don't make films that are as
experimental as that but that overall
idea it just changed my entire way of
thinking i'm so grateful that someone
introduced me to that idea
you know we we live in a media
environment where i think we're very
result oriented
you know how much money does the phone
make what people think of it or the
reviews
um that kind of stuff and as an artist i
really realize i have to be happy with
the process
too and to expl and have a journey in
the process so that was super important
um and i definitely also learned that i
had i had professors who
were super interested in engaging what
was new and risky and exciting
i did also encounter though uh a certain
sort of skepticism sort of new
technology
and i actually really promised myself
that i wasn't going to be someone who
when the new thing came along
i would grumble about it and ignore it i
remember
some a minority of them but a few
professors sort of like
really being against digital cameras for
example they just didn't like them
and they weren't that great at the time
but it was just so clear to me they
would obviously get better
you know here we are years later and i
love film but we have great digital
cameras too
and so i actually had that experience
literally happening as a professor
several years ago i got access to an
oculus rift developer kit
put on the headset and my instant
reaction was like
like i don't like this every tool of
cinema has gone to me i don't have a
frame
i don't have editing you know i don't
have lighting that much
and i was like i don't want to do
anything to do with that and thankfully
in that moment i was like wait wait
you're being that old grumpy professor
don't do that
and so instead i threw myself into it
and i've done a lot of work in vr now
and honestly i spent a long amount of
time
not liking it but still doing it because
i was just convinced
there's got to be something to it and
now i'm at the point where
uh as i've now fully understood it to be
different from film
i do like some things about it uh but
for sure i had to overcome a lot of my
like grumpy old dinosaur filmmaker um
sort of attitude
to sort of see what was good about it
what about that your work is going to
invoke
either not not dislike but anger in some
people like i'm thinking of chris burton
i don't know if you saw
you know you did the lack my lights and
yeah he did a lot of experimental stuff
that made people angry you know and he's
not the only artist but
and being okay with that
i like the idea of movies that provoke
questions and provoke a response
um and i'm perfectly okay with people
not liking the movies you know
if someone uh yeah just it isn't their
cup of tea if they have an objection to
it
uh i will say like i don't know that i'm
a place in my life where i want to make
a movie that i think will be
consciously hurtful to anyone and i do
think about that for sure like
there's a line i think between provoking
deep questioning or challenging dominant
ideas
and then there's another level which is
like yeah but what i don't want to do is
be hateful or hurtful
um and i don't think that i am but like
i do think about that uh
so i'm excited for people to debate the
movies and i'm excited for people
to um sort of engage with them and i'm
even okay with uh
people who are like yeah i didn't really
like it i think that that to me that
doesn't impact my artistic choices
um and i like filmmakers who do that too
there are filmmakers who i respect
whose move they actually don't
particularly like you know um and
uh and i'm glad they exist i think for
me the only thing that i'm
not interested in seeing is where if we
cross the line between
you know uh expressing alternate ideas
to like
essentially being you know hurtful
and now too debbie do you prepare your
students for that because like i'm
gonna date myself again gen x we didn't
have we had party lines you could call a
party line and talk to people you didn't
have social media where you could say
i hated this i hate the filmmaker you're
awful and now
that's a very real part of our culture
even if it's just someone that just
wants to invoke an emotion in the
filmmaker
yeah i mean i think that the the social
media environment is actually the
hardest for those of us that didn't come
of age in it like you know
i when i started a filmmaker as a
filmmaker it was just beginning right
the silicon valley explosion was just
happening
and so for me like yeah it is a i have
to definitely sort of remind myself
anytime i go on twitter
there is a chance that someone is just
going to tell me they hate my movie you
know
actually doesn't happen that often it's
like maybe only one or two times
um but yeah for sure you have to balance
stuff emotionally when you hear that but
when i watch my students i think the
truth is
it's less that they're better at
navigating that but more that that's
just a fact of life for them
in all aspects of life that like
everything they you know that they do
is in some ways always you know uh
subject to a lot of different commentary
or judgment or ideas and so i think
i don't see them as like particularly
sort of thinking about that being unique
to their filmmaking experience
as it is just reflective of their life
experience interesting so maybe older
people
myself i think we're having a hard time
we're having a harder time interesting
okay
well i'm the i feel that way
okay okay great what's been the easiest
year for you as a filmmaker and then
what's been the hardest
the easiest year i think was in some
ways like the most joyful year
was my first year at film school which
was a tremendous amount of work
but totally free of any concern
like i worked so hard to make movies and
i probably you know
stayed up later than i ever had and uh
and
in terms of labor did way more on paleo
than i'd ever done
but it was so easy because there was
actually no real stakes to it we were
just all in film school
if we didn't want to no one even see the
movies and it was such a joy just to
engage with like yep we're just thinking
about movies
uh and the hardest movie the hardest
year was the last year of making this
movie
where i was down to only the scenes that
were difficult to shoot
um where i you know uh
was struggling to balance work and
parenthood and and other life stuff
and you know where quite honestly like
there was a
point at the end of the shooting where
you know i was a little fearful that i
wasn't going to finish it you know and
and and to confront the idea that wow i
might have worked this long
what if i just can't get over the edge
like that sort of
doubt combined with the stakes of as
much as i tried to not spend too much
money we had spent some money you know
that was that i
that i wanted to make sure i used you
know appropriately that was the hardest
year
and once we finished uh shooting and i
got into post then i relaxed because i
knew like
if i got to post even it takes forever
i will have a movie because i understand
how to edit a movie together
the shooting was the hardest part it's
the part i enjoy the most but for sure
that last part of shooting was the
hardest thing i've ever done